Welcome back to Computer Vision.
Today we're going to be learning
about a technique that is important,
in general, but
we sort of slid it here and
we're talking about recognition under
the generative model description.
So, last time we introduced which
I hope for you is the last time.
Certainly for me it was the last time.
They say,
you never forget your first time.
Me, I can barely remember the last time.
Last time we introduced generative
models for classification.
And there are a couple of
points about generative models.
Meghan's still giggling
in the back there.
One of the points was that in general
models you build the new model for
every new object category.
And you don't really
think too much about
the other objects that you know about.
And you just you,
you build the description.
And then when new things come in you
see how likely is the new thing for
each of the description,
each of the models that you have.
But there was another point and
that was perhaps a little more subtle
because it was kind of Flew by.
And that is that generative models
work best in lower dimensional spaces.
And what I mean by that is since we're
going to build these probabilistic
descriptions usually some sort of
probability density function, it's only
plausible to estimate those, and you've
got a modest number of dimensions.
If you have very high dimen,
number of dimensions, or
even, even, even just a moderate
number of dimensions.
To estimate a real probability density
requires lots and lots and lots of data.
So today what we're going to do
is we're going to learn about one
of the most common and, and, perhaps, I
don't want to sa, call it important, but
it, but, just everybody would expect
that you would understand it.
Method of dimensionality reduction,
which referred to as
principal component analysis.
You may have seen this in other
signal stuff, and maybe even in one
of your algebra, but it became,
pretty significant in Computer Vision
because of this particular piece
of work that I'll tell you about.
And it, because of that it
gets used all the time.